en france ce samedi marque une première
historique depuis 1977 jamais une marche
des fiertés n'était parti de banlieue
cette année elle part de pantin de seine
saint denis une façon de démontrer que
le combat de la communauté lgbt ne
concerne pas que la capitale ont défilé
on le retrouve tout de suite notre
reporter nadège d'arzacq l'intérêt
bonjour c'est donc une première pour la
marche des fiertés qui s'est élancé
depuis pontpoint cette année et est
actuellement dans paris la capitale
absolument émirats première depuis 1977
alors ce cortège est parti il ya un peu
plus d'une heure du côté de pantin en
seine-saint-denis alors pourquoi ce
choix de débuter en seine saint denis
dans le 93 et bien c'est avant tout un
choix politique
un choix un choix symbolique pour
montrer justement que le combat ne
concerne pas uniquement la capitale
alors malgré un temps maussade même si
ça s'améliore elles sont plusieurs
milliers de manifestants et bien défiler
à déambuler dans les rues de paris pour
et bien lutter contre les
discriminations et faire valoir les
droits de de la cause homosexuelle je
vous propose d'écouter à certains
manifestants c'est important de défilés
parce qu'on est là pour défendre nos
droits et montrer qu'on est là et qu'on
existe tout simplement et qu'il faut et
qu'il faut se mettre dans l'aisne il
faut montrer que compte la signer et
parce que love is love c'est tout parce
qu'en france les droits n'évolue pas
aussi vite qu'on imagine mais surtout
parce qu'on hongrie en pologne les
droits régresse les deux homosexuels
deviennent des criminels
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on est là pour
eux moi j'ai été personnellement menées
dans des thérapies conversion de 15 à 18
ans dans notre collectif rien à guérir
on est 40 à avoir subi différentes
sévices s'il ya des personnes se sont
fait exorciser des personnes qui se sont
fait à administrer des des hormones des
personnes qui ont subi des viols
correctifs donc non c'est encore
important même en 2021 il ya des progrès
à faire et le gouvernement
malheureusement qui nous avait promis
une loi s'est rétracté nous dit les
thérapies de conversion sont interdites
alors que personne n'a été que c'est
depuis 30 ans condamné pour les taxis
ont donc non pour nous c'est essentiel
de devenir marché défendre nos droits et
dire qu'il faut avancer et en début de
manifestation à des slogans hostiles à
la politique d' emmanuel macron ont été
scandés plusieurs manifestantes appelé à
la démission du président de la
république pourquoi parce qu'ils
estiment que
le chef de l'état et sa politique et son
gouvernement ne font pas suffisamment
pour la cause homosexuelle ils ont
notamment cité l exemple de la
procréation médicalement assistée alors
désormais réservé à toutes les femmes
elles ces manifestants et s'ils veulent
qu'elle soit aussi réservé aux femmes
transsexuelles
merci à nadera pour toutes ces
précisions